i'm not gonna sit here i'm not gonna sit
and accept it and accept it because i've
had like five six messages now a man to
me about oh i'll i'll unsubscribe to
your patreon if you say it's better than
do what you wanna do
do what you wanna do
i said in my teens say that again you're
gonna make a threat
you're gonna threaten me after what i
just said what's going on with these gas
prices you're gonna make threats
about my financial stability
[Music]
don't waste your time with me
i mean honestly
open your eyes and see this guy needs to
drop that album asap or a album at least
brent brent brent
right bren we're talking to you now for
the first minute or so
we already know you're one of the
greatest r b singers going
why are you wasting huh
currently yeah why are you wasting time
not dropping the album
like i'm looking at you directly i know
you're watching this second biggest
podcast in the world come on you've seen
it on the socials come on you've seen it
everywhere like you know you know what
i'm saying like
it's it's annoying that you can bring
out
a couple singles here there and
everywhere bang her off the banger after
banging just get away with it and just
get away with it nonchalantly you're
posting nonsense on the gram instead of
posting the album
you're moving like rihanna and i don't
understand
i just don't understand so yeah he he's
a he fancies himself a rock star that's
why
he hates to play by anyone yeah yeah he
does what he wants then when people ask
for the album the more he doesn't want
to bring it sharp
yeah
who says he's even gonna be an album i'm
just dropping singles because i'm bored
yeah i'll do a one
[ __ ] man yeah we do i would love a brent
album a brent album right now would bang
for the summer
if we had a brent drake and maybe let me
think who else would we need a kendrick
we need a hendrick we need a kendra
not for this summer i couldn't handle it
i would i literally wouldn't be handling
it because i had to fall
um
yeah i can't really think of anyone else
so i'll want to drop an album this
summer
some of i'm trying to think as an artist
who gives me summery vibes rihanna could
do something after the pregnancy yeah
but who wants a post-pregnancy rihanna
they're just just depressed just like
saying who wants a post-pregnancy
beyonce yeah not me you've been done
yeah not me probably she's making
beggars after beggars yeah i know but
she's in like
we're still grieving do you know what i
mean we're not not this summer
in two summers time even yeah in two
summers time rihanna could drop another
oh yeah yeah not this summer i'm pretty
fresh yeah the thing was fresh yeah we
weren't done healing with the fact that
she's dating asap yeah and then next
thing she's nine months pregnant my
sister said
rihanna and that little boyfriend she's
dating i was like you mean big big asap
rocky
i couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it
she's like what what what songs he got
out that's popping i was like asap rocky
don't don't disrespect asap
obviously he's not been dropping in a
minute but he's a fashion mogul don't
disrespect asap like that wow how dare
you that's a
i couldn't believe why yeah with the
reality
it's too soon yeah this summer
we only we hadn't even got over the fact
that she was dating
someone with real status yeah none of
these french billionaires whatever she
[ __ ] feels
yeah yeah someone in the game but she's
dating someone in the game and then two
weeks later she's seven months pregnant
yeah it didn't make any sense for you it
was it was tough for a lot of people
yeah so if she was
audaciously drop an album this summer no
no you haven't won me back yet you
literally haven't even won me back yet
um but nah
uh i don't know who it would be
brent brent definitely for sure he'd
clean up this summer yeah drake can drop
whatever went everywhere yes he does
maybe a young ep yeah yeah in june july
long three four five songs max five
songs with this new brace he's got going
on yeah i already know he's gonna do
something crazy he's gonna try i'm not a
fan of the braves but he's i i i i like
what it does for his confidence yeah you
know
i hate the way he pouts man every time
she's like
you found me
every time he's at a level that you're
not allowed to criticize i know he does
it
because if he was to dare reply to you
there's nothing you can say yeah i know
true if you were to tweet like
i [ __ ] can't stand the way he pouts
in his things and he was to ever reply
and be like
i'll do what i want i'm drake
there's nothing you can say
i'd probably screech it and said it to
you my name
is replied yeah
he could reply and say bro
you're going to screenshot this reply
just to be gas that i even acknowledged
you and you would do it
i would do it so that's why he has
braids yeah and that's why he has a pout
because he literally can't he does what
he wants bro um but yeah i'm not a fan
of the brace but yeah with those braids
i love the the self power that he's
probably gained from that because he
thinks he's saucy he does he thinks he's
saucy he does
he's such a you
he's such a when you actually deep his
life
he's actually you i love him but he's a
you same way michael jackson's are you
yeah yeah yeah but jack jackson took his
too far
literally literally couldn't get over
the fact that he was you yeah but
drake's are you in terms of like
he loves thick [ __ ] too much no
matter what
yeah he loves stick witches no matter
what they look like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he
he's you can tell he's gassed that he's
got braids which is hilarious to me
to the caribbean for the first time
and then someone on the beach just does
the embrace
yeah
um
and what else um the fact that he uses
london slang because he loves under so
much you're a you yeah yeah and that's
fine
but you're actually you and it's
hilarious to me you live a kid's life
he's gonna say he's a kid at heart yeah
he is a proper kid at heart yeah and
yeah he gets emotionally damaged by
every dish he's ever been in yeah and he
looks forward to that part he does he's
toby yeah oh he is toby yeah 100 percent
is toby [ __ ] hell um he must have uh
he must have found it tough when he
found out rihanna was pregnant
he must have wanted to jump brother
because obviously we and we spoke about
this jump in the studio
he went he wanted to jump in the studio
we spoke about this um when you when we
played um what's that track called
[ __ ] fans in your whip oh when we're
going to the old studio
yeah and it's like oh that could have
been my up in there
yo
yo he's he's regretted losing her for so
long for so long man ah it's the game
though man if you're gonna be out your
[ __ ] fans then those are the prices
you're gonna have to pay [ __ ] man
you thought you could just do anything
and get away with it and still have
rihanna by his side bro that's when
you're at that level of royalty that's
what you're going to think yeah true
because that's what everyone's telling
you true and that's the life you're
living sometimes you you're going to get
caught up one shot too many bro it's
game over
sorry g tough but you can still have
anyone you want you can except rihanna
literally except when you're at that
caliber that's what's going to piss you
off yeah yeah he wants anyone and
everyone at any given time yeah he wants
yeah anyone wants he literally he wants
to be like rihanna now yeah and it's
done
oh lucky they can drop so i'm annoying
mm-hmm i don't really listen to that
much but i listen to the last album
lucky day would be a strong candidate
for a summer uh summer release
who else uh there's a guy like called
black party okay uh oh
what kind of genre are we looking at um
it's like r and b ish like new age r b
he's nice he's nice with it okay um
thames could drop sighting if she wants
thames good job saying if [ __ ] jumps
replay is one of my favorite songs i've
heard of 2021 swear replay for me
wow it's a vibe i just get that island
vibe and i'm just happy every time i
hear that yeah yeah yeah she does i love
that song nice i [ __ ] love that song
um is there anyone else
i'm always ready for some dojo cat
speaking of doja yeah yeah have you seen
or heard
um it's called handstand french montana
featuring dojika and
sweetie i don't think so bro is it
banger
first of all yes it's a banger second of
all
i don't know if it was ghost written but
this is the best french montana verse
i've ever heard oh really it definitely
goes written there is the like the verse
how he spits and like
the rhyming the flow everything but
obviously i won't play now because it's
a youtube episode i don't know what it
is
but
handstand
uh french montana dojika and sweetie
banger all right i'll pray remind me as
soon as we turn that camera off remind
me and i'll banger yeah banger gang say
that it's one of the ones where if
you're in the shops
and there's galley about stop you're
sitting down and you're just watching oh
you're just watching it shakedown
[Music]
[Laughter]
banger fair play the way odd the way
french spits on that track wow i
couldn't believe it i couldn't believe
definitely go through it all right
definitely goes through uh
definitely that's so disrespectful
don't get me wrong but he's a [ __ ]
rapper yeah yeah he's he's a terrible
boy he obviously not necessarily does it
for the p but he's found his niece she's
found his market and he's run with it
and i don't blame him the same way the
new boys did it with the euro jerk and
stuff they found their god didn't they
just and you just run with it i'm not
mad uh dj mustard he found his tempo and
he ran with it i'm not mad he's not the
best rapper but
couldn't believe that verse
sorry just leave it at that fair play
couldn't believe that um since we're on
the topic of pop culture yes got a trash
news yes which is frustrating because by
the time we release this episode it's
going to be like a week old but i don't
care because we haven't spoken about it
that's all i care about what goes on in
these four walls yes
um
my guy pete davidson finally clapped
back i saw he
finally caught up with a picture fan i
saw emma say where are you i'm in bed
with your wife yo with a young peace
sign
and then kanye was like so who's looking
after my kids
who's looking after my kids
shut up
i'm in bed with your wife though this
back and forth needs to stop
and do you know the peak thing about
the initial um conversation or that
initial conversation man said hi it's
skeet yeah he parted himself in the
first instance but that's pete davidson
in a nutshell true he is a comedian so i
guess here's him
i guess um but he was waiting to drop
that pic he was i'm in bed with your
wife oh that's painful but he came on to
him on a humble thing he did and just
said this whole thing is long
where i got lost in that conversation
well actually i didn't even i didn't
even read all of it yeah because the
point where i got locked where i locked
it off even was when um
man said
big man
come sunday service we'll hash it out
yeah yeah yeah and i said i'm not coming
some day service meet me at such and
such and we can chat or this game and
meet me before the game instead of that
and then man said come sunday like you
need sunday service as soon as he said
sunday service the second time i'm not
reading the rest of this because this is
silly chat now this is silly chat all i
wanted to see was the the clap back yeah
i'm in bed with your wife i was
satisfied
he he had to he did something he stood
up for himself so props to him who
shared the thing though
kanye i've seen it on kanye's connie
shared the whole combo i've seen on
connie because i only follow connie i
don't follow pete oh okay and i've seen
it on his instagram yeah unless i saw it
on like a shade room thing and i just
assumed it was cardio's yeah i
definitely saw it in shade room okay let
me okay let me actually check i'm pretty
sure it's kind of you go to connie i'll
go to p and see who posted it first
or if it was done in the same hour we
won't know but oh no it definitely
wasn't carny because it's not on it it's
not on there it's not unless he's
deleted it connie's now got three
pictures
unless he's deleted it in that time
big man just pete doesn't even have a
[ __ ] instagram i have no idea i don't
follow him
um
what it wasn't the sh
oh it may have been the shade room i
definitely didn't see it it was
definitely shade room that i saw i
definitely saw on cartier he's deleted
i definitely definitely definitely saw
him sure 100 he's deleted all right
let's say it's kind of it's because i
can't even find this nigga's [ __ ]
because on this the way it looks on the
shade room wasn't the way i saw it like
this is what it looks like a shady room
and this is not why how i read it oh
okay i read it as actual screenshots
yeah so yeah he's definitely deleted
weird
uh speaking of
um going on to the fun fact this
actually bodes in well because i
remember you said i i hope um cudi and
chica got 100 mil for the documentary
what do they get 300 ml
no they've got 30 ml
yeah that's obviously i know you've seen
it but those haven't obviously you've
not seen genius yet then i don't know
what you've been doing um but
chike and cody were the guys that
obviously um did a documentary for kanye
over the past 20 years
uh so for 20 years they earned nothing
that they earned nothing directly from
the project until last year netflix
reportedly paid 30 million for the
footage 30 million dollars for the
footage that 30 million dollars now
works out as 750 000 each
per year
what the each year that they were
filming
750 bags per year each each that little
filament yeah that seems like a
reasonable
healthy amount of money there is but
it's the only thing is sorry to cut you
guys fine
um
ah
that works out well if you're getting
paid 750 mil
whilst you're doing it of course but he
was suffering yeah yeah he was starving
while he did it that needs a little bit
more to me yeah
that means a bit more to me yeah um but
still regardless that's [ __ ]
mad healthy
can you see yourself ever
quitting your day-to-day job and be like
okay boom
i feel like these guys are going to be
the ones i'm going to edit for them for
the rest for like 20 years bro yeah no
because i'm i'm too selfish for that i'm
i can't ever imagine
me seeing such
like
light from another human being
that i would would dedicate my life to
documenting their life yeah
like i can't imagine seeing someone's
aura overshadow my own story so much
that like i consider myself irrelevant
in this tale
and that my purpose is just to tell
their story
i'm yeah i've got too much of a gold
complex for that yeah i think i'm too
cool for that
i find that
amazing
but also extremely confusing
yeah do you think you could do it uh no
i definitely don't think i can do it
whatsoever um it's
it's just an eye opener because
obviously
cudi was there for like 20 years or
whatever
and you've seen everything now right
you've seen the last episode and
everything yeah it was it was tough to
see how kanye was treating him towards
the tail end of the documentary yeah
before they actually reconnected again
and blah blah blah became friends or
whatever or became friends again or
whatever it was just like
yo this guy was with you he's the not
necessarily he's the reason why you've
elevated to such a certain amount but
if he hadn't had all of this documentary
the [ __ ] um through the wire video
never would have been done yeah 100 and
that was that was your stepping stone
into this world brother that was the
reason the homeboy said your album can
come out
exactly dame dash was like after seeing
this yo pen to paper your album's pushed
through
like little things like that he
he obviously knows he he owes him a lot
he knows one of the ones where he knows
but i feel like i'm not sure he does
know that because he's got so much i
think
uh from just from that perspective i
also think he
is so adamant
that his journey
was going to happen that in his mind he
probably sees it as a way of like
regardless if cody didn't exist and
regardless if the through the via video
never happened the way it happened in
his head i'm sure he would be confident
to think i would have made it happen
regardless because that's his whole
energy his mantra yeah his whole mantra
for the whole thing is no matter what
obstacles people put my way i will make
it happen yeah so i'm sure in his head
he probably thinks regardless of goody
never even documented this
if he never shot the video regardless of
anything i would have made it happen
regardless which is
very good for your own
like motivations but also horrible for
relationships yeah it destroys
relationships yeah yeah man called him
cheeky three or four times on a live
interview bro after he said stop calling
me chikei couldn't cheat
straight off the bat again oh man it was
tough it was tough to see i also i
didn't sorry to keep going guys sorry to
be going back on this um carne
documentary not necessarily i didn't
like the last episode but i much
preferred the first two because it
showed a deep dive of his struggle and
how he tried to be who he is today pre
his mother's um passing and stuff like
all the stuff he had to go through
obviously now because it's because it's
a lot more in social media we kind of
know what has been happening in his past
what five six five six years or whatever
did you also know obviously he ran for
president right oh forgot about that and
let's say there were like eight
candidates he wasn't even the bottom one
oh yeah no there was someone below him
more people voted for him than they did
someone else and i was like [ __ ] out
yeah i mean yeah i do get that but then
i also think that he's so famous that
that's
it's all you're always going to get like
a certain percentage of people that are
just going to vote for him because
he's kanye west yeah you got his die
hards
then you've got psychotic people that
actually think you could do a good job
and then you've got people that would
just do it for the fun of it who hate
the regime that they're in and they'd
rather just have a laugh and waste their
vote quite unquote where's their kanye
west that's what i believe so it doesn't
surprise me considering how famous he is
that i'm surprised he was he was
wasn't higher than what he was based
just on those percentages
but yeah still like
the fact that he thought he could uh run
for president and win is
concerning he still think he still
thinks he's going to win he's still
going to run again apparently he says
2024 he's going to run again i think the
rock should run and i think the rock
would win the rock might win
i think he's going to run not should i
think he's going to run and i think he
will win for the president yeah
i i think he'll try and be governor or
something that's what i was going to say
i think he's going to i think he should
do like a governor senator type thing
and he definitely will clean up same way
like arnold schwarzenegger did i think
he would clean the [ __ ] up i wouldn't be
surprised if he tries to be [ __ ]
governor of hawaii or some [ __ ] or maybe
la and then um
swindle that into a presidential career
a presidential career what what a story
to tell your use bro
moment from
poverty to wrestling
to movies to owning his own company
production company
to governor to president
wow
wow strong story like if
i was his son i'd be vexed because i
can't live up to that yeah you're going
to be a drug addict
that's the truth though
that is the truth you're going to be so
vet
because there's nothing there's nothing
i can do that i would personally say
that okay i've achieved something or
i've bested my dad the only thing you
can think is the thing the only thing
you can do to beat the rock is be a
professional nfl player
because yeah the man was injured and
yeah yeah yeah
that's all you could do very [ __ ]
true he was successful
[ __ ] true you could tell that very
[ __ ] extreme i care if you're a
president you cannot make it a field
i've got a ring big man what have you
got
i've got a [ __ ] ring you've got some
oval office thing
shut your mouth
you absolute [ __ ] oh speaking of nfl
did you see that um tom brady wants to
get back in action again he's going to
he doesn't want yeah he's going
someone tweeted um he spent two months
with his wife and kids and said [ __ ]
them kids i want to go back into work
yeah 100 percent [ __ ] you know i'm not
surprised bro man i saw christianity
i was like yeah i need to i need to
throw some balls again people who
work at that level
and have that level of drive i don't
know why they kid themselves into
thinking that one day they can just stop
stop it all yeah and stay at home yeah
it must feel like time is in slow motion
today yeah like they must literally be
itching of course of course bro that's
probably why obviously people like
ronaldo haven't stopped people like tom
brady obviously going back into the game
hasn't stopped like messi
i understand people get obsessed with
golf and [ __ ]
it you always need something
that takes that gives you a break
you always need something like that like
the same thing with me
and this for example like
when i was fully fully fully into
hospitality and still working five days
a week on blah blah and we were doing
this on the side it was one of those
ones where yes i eventually knew that
this would pay my wages and pay my life
but it was also a release for me because
it was fun it was energetic with you
like it was it was a hobby as well as a
job
whereas now that there's somewhat isn't
any safety net anymore i know i need to
find something else because i can't get
just lost in this i need to find a hobby
that
one can bring me as much somewhat joy as
this brings me and also bring me some
form of financial gratitude as well
because it's i wouldn't be doing the
hobby for financial gratitude but also
be something that i know i can
push as something else on the side yeah
because i'm gonna need a hobby i'm gonna
need something
i've been thinking about hobbies
recently oh your pattern though am i
your pattern with editing
yeah i don't yeah but to me it's like uh
i don't find editing a hobby anymore
yeah it's more strenuous yeah yeah of
course
of course the type of editing i do is
not like i like i like being [ __ ] at
something and getting good at it
and like what i do with the editing and
stuff right now is fine like i'm okay at
it
but like the only way to elevate my
editing would be to
edit different [ __ ] like if i wanted to
like i used to i'm very interested in um
editing to music
okay so like um when i used to do those
like anime style videos yes the music
or whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah
i used to
i would love to like edit like music
videos and stuff like that but it's like
bro sorry well i already told you you're
going to do adverts one day i've been
saying this
bro i don't want to do that yep but you
don't know you've never done one yeah
but i know i don't want to do it okay i
just it doesn't intrigue me okay it
doesn't i i i appreciate i don't want to
dismiss your compliment because i
understand you're paying me a very nice
compliment but stuff like that doesn't
interest me okay i
i don't know what i was gonna say i'm
saying
move on no you're not saying okay you're
not saying okay you're saying everything
but okay but your mouth is saying okay
say less okay
okay okay okay um but now i like in
terms of like hobbies and stuff like
that i i like um
i like competitive elements and i like
um obviously
into a to a certain degree i do enjoy
but i do also like like the difficulty
of editing
so like i like editing in a way that
someone can look at it and be like
that's some sick editing which is why i
would say editing adverts would never
intrigue me because it's like no one's
ever looked at an advert and thought ra
the editor deserved that bike
it's just an advert
like the only part that intrigues me
about editing is just like what you can
do with it
and like the way you can manipulate it
to be like right you've
you've created an its own story yeah
just by editing something that we had no
idea it could be this
um so that something like that as well i
like about music like i i'm fascinated
about like uh
music videos and stuff because you can
do it any which way uh and i think it
would be cool but also
i don't like editing that much i like it
i like it a lot to be fair but i don't
like it enough to be like this is what
i'm gonna do yeah this is what i want to
learn to do like i like learning [ __ ] so
like that's why i used to be so into
jiu-jitsu and stuff yes because it's
like it's a steep learning curve yeah
yeah it's a steep like it's highly
competitive and it's a steep learning
curve and i do want to get back into it
but the times just aren't timing right
now i'm trying to get back into the gym
and the morning sessions are working
with me but the
uh jiu jitsu class is always in the
evening it's like i'm not gonna go and
the gym for me is like half an hour from
me so i'm not gonna drive half an hour
to the gym go to gym drive half an hour
home and then later on that same night
drive half an hour again go to jiu jitsu
it's not gonna happen yeah so it's just
pissing me off but maybe you couldn't
start maybe when last year did you go
jiu-jitsu by the way oh my god time ago
maybe you can start doing once a week
because if you do it once you'd be like
[ __ ] i've missed this you know yeah i
know but even that but the thing is as
well is like
i also don't want that because i'm
willing to do that once a week but it's
like
i don't want to put myself in a position
where i'm i'm spending two hours of my
day driving to a gym and back and forth
it's just not productive yeah it's just
not a good way for people to live their
life yeah it and then it's just yeah gas
prices and the environment and all them
thing there the climate and all that
it's just not it's not healthy it's not
a way to live your life i've seen a
tweet about gasting right
and where they said
someone put um 10 pounds in pump free
and he was like where do you think it's
gonna get to you just pump four
gas prices are teeth bro bro i just
don't understand this inflation the
other day i put 30 quid in there
and i think it gave me 100 miles
which in context is is
pathetic
pathetic
[ __ ] man
maybe less than 100 miles actually i
think it gave me less than maybe like 80
miles you petrol diesel your petrol what
was it saying at the time one what 100
and what uh
well the price yeah uh it's 1.7
this was a few days ago probably 1.72
sound like that down the road i saw one
that was like 1.85 [ __ ] man
elita these men are scamming everyone
when it hits two yeah the world's gonna
i'm walking yeah wherever it is i'm
walking
when it hits two yeah the world is gonna
implode
because these gas prices aren't making
sense yeah from whatever's going on in
russia
it's affecting the world putin needs to
lock it so we can remove these sanctions
and get our gas and oil fam because this
is long i don't want to pay these prices
who's being punished here
him or us
who's really being punished because the
ladies might not also drop in um
electric bills as well
oh my god i've not got one yet but i'm
seeing bills for like
salaries yeah i've seen bills for
monthly salaries james
1800 1900 a month
and i'm not going to lie to you james
it's petrifying me
big big british british gas big big
british gas no i'm telling you now
no one could run a bill to my yard for
1800 pounds i'll move out bro i'm not
paying that petrifying me i'm not gonna
lie you're not gonna get over 1800. i'm
telling you that now
but
bella keeps telling me because ours is
sorry to cut you off ours is quarterly
she keeps reminding me do it monthly
because of this oil change fam fam do it
[ __ ] your mother i always forget to be
fair quarterly i didn't know you were
talking quarterly yeah quarterly yes you
might see something around around that
rate
no these men were showing me monthly
prices for 18 hours
monthly
for what a hotel i don't know i don't
know james
but all i'm saying i'm seeing
screenshots of what they're showing me
so it's making me scared oh because i
can't pay them prices you should be
electricity you should be scared i saw a
gas one my boys showed me a gas one the
other day that was four bills a month
just gas it's not even green electric
four bills and you still got water as
well water and water to go no no no no
no no
[Music]
i'm so happy i only have two utility
balls [ __ ] oh you don't have gas at all
no gas in it all electric all electric
and water that's it
fair play but then obviously that just
runs up the electric yeah from some you
might have to lay some solder panels on
your mezzanine this message you're so
proud of panelists so proud
you [ __ ]
yeah fam this is tough out here [ __ ] i
need to change it i need to change it
today or tomorrow i'm 100 also when my
lease runs out i'm 100 getting an
electric car okay
100 okay the way these gas prices are
moving yeah get an electric car i was
thinking about doing it anyway but the
only thing that puts me off is these
charging times bro i was just about to
say because obviously it's one of them
ones where they have to install the
charging thing at your
yard yeah yeah yeah and it's one of
those also one of those ones where you
don't necessarily know where you can
charge it once you leave yard
oh it's a flip flip of course you know
what i mean yeah you could do a journey
one day
and there might not be a charging point
at point b yeah i think i'm gonna have
to play it
by ear
and be like if i'm driving if for
whatever reason i'm driving to wales
it's a petrol thing it's gonna have to
be a petrol thing
right so you're gonna have two whoops
yeah
you think your boy can't find two ways
i'm just asking brother cause man said
petrol like you can switch the engine
out i'm asking i don't know well word on
the street i've got inside sauce word on
the street is in a couple years maybe
three or four years yeah uh volkswagen
group
yes that's volkswagen audi
uh skoda sia
uh
who else
maybe like porsche someone
a higher class one as well
um
completely electric
okay they're switching to 100 electric
okay in a couple years okay
and i [ __ ] with audis so
my one would definitely and plus i've
seen they make some of the buffett's
electric cars visually okay these are
these in general yeah like the queue
they've got like the new q range that's
like each one the e-tron range okay
that's like they've got like a q4 coupe
okay is that the one that we saw in was
it i think it was improv that was a
different color to yours like the e
range you said the e no that was the r
sport
that's petrol and that's a filthy car it
would look sexy yeah it was fillers
that's petrol petrol yeah can imagine
yeah unless you're yeah you if you've
got that you need to stay within
birmingham
because your engine is big yeah
you're not making it down the empty yeah
guys we're going to take a very very
quick break to shed some love over our
boys and girls over at man escaped so
guys as you know spring has officially
sprung and our friends at manscape have
the best tool for some spring cleaning
in your pants
trust me your confidence will be
blooming like a sky high like the
flowers is upcoming spring time to clear
out the winter bush and join the other
four million men who trust manscaped uh
to use the right tools for the job
now inside
this
care bundle
when you get the performance package 4.0
right you're going to buy the
performance package 4.0 and inside
you're going to find the lawnmower 4.0
that's a trimmer it has an led light
it's waterproof
it has anti-nick technology also you're
going to find the weed whacker for the
nose and ears hairs that's exactly
we've got the crop preserver bull
deodorant crop reviver toner and the
performance boxer briefs
smooth smooth if that wasn't enough
you're going to get a travel bag
um to hold all of these goodies okay
guys so all you need to do is head on
over to manscape.com
manscape.com the code is sng sierra
november come on and that's going to get
you 20 off plus free shipping once more
from the top manscape.com the code is
sng sierra november golf twenty percent
off free shipping worldwide guys let's
get back to the episode thank you very
much [ __ ] petrol prices ah yeah so
yeah from these um
these petri prizes need to take a break
i just want to live come to the gas
prices electric prices petrol prices
they only take a break i just want to
live comfortably yeah so
we will but yeah that's long
um at the moment so um right
i'm going to do a quick segment yeah and
then i want to take a shot left hand
because
um
so obviously
no i'm not i'm not gonna take the sharp
turn now because i can't separate my
attention and do and and laugh like
everything's all right with this new
segment
and then keep what's on my brain
okay
so i'm gonna take the sharp left turn
now okay and then i'll do my segment
okay so i said this to you before we
turned it on okay but then i've had it
like three more times
since
um
i've had like three more times since i
brought it up earlier okay so obviously
in the last week's episode i said that
potentially i never even said it i said
potentially i said potentially the
batman movie as a whole may be better
than the dark knight yeah amanda's
trying to chuck it to me yeah disclaimer
i've not seen it i'm watching you you
haven't seen it yeah
yeah i'm not gonna do any spoilers but
i'm not gonna sit here i'm not gonna sit
and accept it and accept it because i've
had like five six messages now a man to
me about oh i'll i'll unsubscribe to
your patreon if you say it's better than
do what you wanna do
do what you wanna do
i said in my dms say that again you're
going to make a threat
you're going to threaten me after what i
just said what's going on with these gas
prices you're going to make threats
about my financial stability
and you're gonna expect me to sit here
yeah and apologize yeah no no no
no no no no no no no you got me [ __ ]
up that's hilarious
right so it's annoying because i really
need to see both movies back to back to
give a proper analysis but also this is
this is triggering me so i need to get
it off my chest now otherwise i can't
move on with the episode right
you will see so you can come back and
see
after you said the scene the movie think
what you want to think right in my
opinion
and obviously this goes it's like like
you'd like to say it's double-edged
because
it's a relevant point but also an
irrelevant point
if you take the dark knight right
take
the uh these amount of movement
furniture next door is pissing me off
um
without heath ledger's joker take any
other joker that the batman universe has
ever brought to the table
i don't even know so we've got um
jack nicholson i was gonna say play the
joker but i've seen it i've seen
i don't think i've seen any movie that
dragon has played a joke bad know he
played the joker if that's nice so we've
got jack nicholson's joker
we've got um
i'm going to google it while you're
speaking homeboy who's now playing
morbius what's his [ __ ] name i know
who you're talking about but
long hair what the [ __ ] is his name i
want to i want to be accurate with that
i'm making mobius uh his name is
such a method actor what's his [ __ ]
name
um why does it never show the actors
when ah jared
he's a [ __ ] good joker yeah but he
doesn't fit that movie yeah whatsoever
very very very different so if you take
let's just take those three right yeah
jack nicholson joaquin phoenix and um
jared leto if you take those three
jokers and put them in the dark knight
that dark knight movie is trash it's
very different it's very heath ledger
epitomized the joker in that movie yeah
he not necessarily made the movie but he
made the movie yeah yeah
thank you yeah yeah look thinking about
it now yeah
he was
he was such a villain that he was a hero
in that movie i challenge anyone to
think of any scene that's memorable in
that movie that the joker's not in that
scene
the joke the relationship between the
joker and batman made the movie without
him without heath
it would have been a very different
movie bro yeah and
even any bruce wayne moments were
irrelevant in that movie were irrelevant
even when they tried to bring in
two-face into that movie basic villain
in that movie he played a basic this it
didn't even make sense that the degree
of turn of his personality didn't even
make sense there wasn't even enough
build-up yeah he's all of a sudden his
missus is dead and he's a serial killer
now it don't make sense big man these
men want to chuck it to me about that
they forced that out you found faucets
and i'm getting hyper now
tempo's picking up doesn't want to get
me vexed yeah because i remember the
hospital scene was like this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah baking it with two they begged
it with two face
um
the the the the batman scene the solo
batman scenes were shallow they were
shallow i don't remember that them that
much but
shallow scenes the bruce way scenes were
shallow scenes with rachel
shallow love connection
there was no depth there was no real
collection rachel's an irrelevant
character
irrelevant character so two faces
irrelevant rachel's irrelevant bruce
wayne in that film is irrelevant
anything without the joker the only
relevant scene in that whole movie
without the joker is the plot between
the two cruise ships or whatever it was
with the prison of the sun that's the
only relevant scene in batman's not even
in that scene and his mom would attach
it to me and say that i'm off-key i'm
off-key because i said the batman movie
as a whole
is potentially better than the dark
knight as a movie as a whole replace
heath ledger the actor heath ledger with
any other of his his colleagues
of his clansmen of the other joker and
that movie doesn't work so [ __ ] you if
you if
because i need to have a better
breakdown of what what movie said what
but off the top of my head i can already
give you a million examples as to why
it's better so don't even come for me in
my dms next man that says from your dm's
you're in trouble
say less because these men think i'm
just saying yeah yeah yeah these might
think i'm just saying [ __ ]
you got your facts to back it up you've
got your face to back up i i'll i'll
yeah sorry for that outburst but
honestly no it's a necessity sometimes
it is a necessity sometimes but um
people have to know
before you have you've got a segment as
well haven't you yeah yeah but i've got
one in me that actually was a
contribution from uh one of our fans
okay
uh which i will find
give me a sec so this is just some
confessions yeah okay this is from lad
bible's fest hole
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
some of these confessions sent this to
me brutal bro
brutal i skimmed through it yeah hit me
again all right okay cool remember
this one yes yeah
split up with the misses a few months
ago as she was seeing someone else who
she's now moved into our marital home
i still have the hive heating app on my
phone
i keep turning up to maximum when they
go to work i hope it's costing them a
fortune
what we just spoke about
that's torture that is torture that
man's bill is going to be different
imagine coming in from work it's just
toasty in here
and the bills are coming through bro i'd
be living up a walking finger i'm sure i
switched this [ __ ] off
i'm sure i did fam you're [ __ ] with
the timer day in day out coming in the
bills are sky high i'd be i'd want to
shoot from you're on the phone
complaining complaining brother one of
you man he's come down here now
grab an engineer bro immediately
grab an engineer immediately
god these prices are making sense bro oh
my days yeah
right
i've been utterly besotted by a taken
man for most of my adult life i knew
nothing would ever happen but still
fantasized he recently used holly bob's
in a text
and i am finally
mercifully
100 cured
mercifully it literally takes one thing
to make a girl be like
yuck perhaps it doesn't make sense yuck
that jay said it best they resent the
fact that they
they resent the fact that they're
heterosexual yeah women resent the fact
that they're heterosexual they hate the
fact that i like mandib they hate it
because
essentially we're useless to them at
times essentially we are and it's like
just they look at us sometimes think oh
man some of the stuff you do oh man yeah
let's
think what you want to think
think what you want to think because
you're going to get this pipe regardless
you're going to want to get this pipe
regardless this brings me on to my um i
had a thought the other day and i was
thinking you know yeah
most men haven't got the trick i think
i've
well we've brought up briefly in the
past but most men haven't got the trick
down bro in terms of in terms of like
the best way
to combat the ick is never to find icks
for women
is to completely and utterly own the ick
to the point where you're aggressive
with it yeah
okay to the point where you're
aggressive yeah so say if like oh like
ich ah he can't dance ick
yeah
i'm all shoulders yeah i want shoulders
me yeah
yeah eat me you slag yeah
you're a slack ick me if you don't want
to be about it then don't be a bad yeah
yeah yeah i'm me fat i'm me this is who
i am yeah this is who i am all you want
i'm not even gonna i'm gonna say you're
buyers you're not even buyers bro your
peg ick me
because i'm a grown man this is who i am
no i don't
it's like
the audacity because i've had people as
a joke whatever
like dm me and be like uh or like um i
might post a story and someone might dm
me like ick
is this your business
the audacity that you think you can dm
someone yeah and say
i know you don't know me but whatever
you're doing in your life is turning me
off um
your business
that's your business excuse me
one of them wants excuse me the
entitlement yeah he needs to know
that the way he's living his life
is putting me off him
bro um
i was wearing this was time ago i was
wearing um
my asos gym top is that it's called 4505
which represents asos yeah and someone
wrote oh you've got numbers in your
shirt it looks like some cult activity
what i didn't reply obviously i don't
care less about people like that and
then
i think she dms me again this is one of
the ones that in my request that i never
read of course yeah i've got like 700 in
there
damn to me again i can't remember what i
posted but she gave me like heart eyes
or whatever it's like so what you were
talking about last week away from here
so what were you talking about last week
then about this cult activity
you're just here to try and chat [ __ ]
and gain attention no
no
it's not gonna work it's not gonna work
[ __ ] you it's just not gonna work um but
yeah man like man them stop trying to
find because guys dm me on a daily basis
like oh oh oh info mending for me now
brother just own it
own it
yeah i'm i'm shook to pull out into a
busy street
i'm terrified say something
i can see it now i can see it now
because if you hesitate yeah
a young joke
yeah oh
no i'm [ __ ] terrified to be here what
are you going to say oh yeah say what
you want to say a young joke whoever's
in that car will look at you twice
but look at you twice i swear bro i
i feel bad this happened recently as
well i feel bad that now like
through the art of laughter we have just
enabled
these women to create more eggs for
dudes yeah
and now dudes that i care about are
suffering
there's there's one brother i play
there's one friend we play warzone with
from time to time
and um
he was on the chat and one time he was
like oh like my missus um
loves your show kind of thing
and then one of our boys jumped in and
was like
big mistake
if your missus listens to a show she
hates men
recently he dm me a text between them
and she was like you know what you gave
me the egg the other day and i was like
fam i'm actually sorry
you shouldn't have to live in fear like
that
in your own home oh
wait she messaged her own man her own
man you said you gave me the ick
that's tough
it's not on is it that's tough it's
actually not on it's not on it's not
fair in a safe space
fam safe space under my own roof yeah
that's tough
i'm sorry
um fam this one is the funniest one i
read out of all of them okay this is the
funniest one i've read out of all of
them okay hear me i'm a bus driver yeah
if i'm having a bad day at work i'll
look in the mirror while driving and
mutter to myself
you're all [ __ ] aren't you and then tap
the brakes twice so they nod
[Laughter]
what a sociopath
oh my days
i can imagine seeing the eyes there and
be like you know [ __ ] aren't you and
they're just
and everyone's
and he just loves it he oh he loves it
he's like yeah you're all cuz oh i read
that one i remember that was hilarious
hilarious oh my days
um
my wife bought a dash cam for our car
i didn't recorded the sound in the car
she now has lots of recordings of me
pretending to be interviewed by sp
by sky sports as manager of my fifa team
yo
he now knows
she has his life in a chokehold oh
because he she could embarrass him at
any given moment oh a million percent he
has to fix up and look sharp all the
time he has to fall in line oh
it's a pity bro
last one
neighbor really pissed me off once can't
remember why
for the next few weeks i'd get up early
on bin day
bring his full bin in and then put it
back once the lorry's gone he'd go
[ __ ] ballistic when he found out it's
been still full
that's torment that is tall man i said
i've read that one that's totally
dormant
fear that's not on that's torment and
that's also dedication on his part oh i
haven't got time for that early morning
early days i haven't got time for that
wake up push his bin back and then go
back nah bro
i would knowing me
knowing [ __ ] me if i'm one of those
guys that are looking up waiting to see
if my bin got taken or whatever and i'm
realizing we can wake up fam i'm putting
i am putting my trash out every tuesday
yeah yeah putting the bins out every
tuesday yeah and every tuesday it's
still full yeah i promise you on one
tuesday i'm gonna be looking out the
window at 5 30 in the morning and seeing
my neighbor doing it fam
i don't know whether i would scare him
or want to dash a stone at him
but i'm retaliating either way i'll be
so livid i want to be so living i'm
retaliating in a way that's going to get
me locked up
and then when you when when the jury
need to hear my justification
it's not going to make sense
it'll be so paid
within an inch of his life because he
was [ __ ] with your bins
you're like yeah if you haven't got the
context
[Music]
you don't understand unless you don't
get it from where am i supposed to put
my bids
week in week out week in week out this
is [ __ ] oh that's hilarious you
can't expect someone to live like that
yeah that is hilarious yeah i've said it
before big men hold all the cards they
do because as soon as they go on strike
what are we supposed to do
especially in the summer months what the
[ __ ] are we saying we're spelling
everything spending this hot humid oh no
no no no no they want to be paid
pay them what they want to be paid bro
dude if i need to pay extra tax for it
do it because my bins need to be gone
bro
one time someone someone put their bin
in my bin yeah nah
i went nuts
fam i [ __ ] flung it on the floor and
it split open
and i wanted them to be to be watching
what yeah who is it
run your ship i've been one more time
bro i swear to
god oh my days [ __ ] hell man oh
that's hilarious yeah being part of a
society is so
embarrassing sometimes for sure because
you get obsessed with the most pathetic
little [ __ ] and it makes you realize
like we're not meant for this we're not
meant to live on a street of people who
don't know
i hear that i hear that you're meant to
live with your like tight little
community yeah yeah and that's just
that's it that everyone understands you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um you had a segment yes um so one of
these ones this actually got sent to me
um
i think sent a sent to me personally
you're sent to us
um so obviously a few weeks ago
we did um
we did the meanest thing a guy has said
to you
yes remember yes so after doing that i
got several screenshots of
comments on another tick tock video of
the meanest things women have said to
you
so i went on tick tock shout out you
know who you are so say for sunday night
and i went on tick tock read through the
comments and they are
juicy swear juicy swear juicy you might
have to put the fan on because you're
gonna strike okay before we do it please
i need to piss yeah and then i'm gonna
take a shot yeah and then i'll put the
fan on yeah i wanna i wanna set it up
yeah cool
see all right guys
the meanest thing a woman has said to
you obviously this isn't fan sent in
this isn't fan requested but
i might run it back in a few weeks we'll
see
but yeah
i'm so excited
this is the this was the first comment
the top comment
thousands of likes all right go go go go
go go go go acting a little too tall for
your actual height
no
no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's
triggering that's triggering that that's
triggering
that's triggering i couldn't listen to
me james listen to me listen listen to
me listen
i know this is all fun and games when
you do this right
but i promise you yeah i genuinely don't
know how i would respond if a yacht told
me that face to face you're acting a
little too tall
for your actual height big man relax
because you act a little bit too tall
for your actual height
i would where whatever vicinity i'm in
i'm getting locked up oh 100 i'm getting
locked up she said
you're too short to chat to me like that
big man
she went for my job
she knew the reaction i would get and
she ran with it anyway yeah yeah yeah
anyway that's not on
she lives in hellfire yeah she loves
torment
bro
wow
i don't understand how you have the
audacity to keep acting up like there's
not a full line behind you
like there's not a full line behind you
brother
man saying you're only in this spot
because i deem so
i could lock you off like that nah bro
this can't run
women are treacherous
ah to be fair the men's ones were
[ __ ] sad
let's set up your antidepressants
you're not leaving man
all right next one next one
i'm not bored enough to talk to you
right now bye
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no roll the waving emoji as well no
i'm not bored enough to talk to you
right now bye
[ __ ] you
you have to scream into your pillow yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah kick your legs
yeah yeah yeah of course of course just
lost we've lost everything women know
how to really strip the power from you
that's what they do best it's like
bro
when you said that it reminded me so
much of that video of
the girl saying to the guy oh but you're
bold though and he comes out of his car
it fizzing [ __ ] touch treasury
[ __ ] touched me she's stripped from
she's anything
but you've got no hair oh that's exactly
what was oh
honey you've got no she said it's so
nonchalantly it blew his brains out
touch me [ __ ] it he got funniest i've
ever seen
that's the funniest video i've ever seen
he was fizzing touch me and i said [ __ ]
don't judge me
they strip the power you have
they strip it bro whatever you've got
fam give it to whatever you think you've
got whatever you think you've got give
it to me
based on the smallest of insecurities
he's brutal you're too short
other men want me
you're bald
men have to really the men get the worst
rap because they really have to
dig deep yeah yeah this is why your mum
has no hair yeah yeah you need to up
your antidepressant dosage because i
cheated on you and you're not leaving me
yeah all these men have to in order to
get at women yeah men really like you
should starve yourself like men really
have to go outside and blame a disabled
sister yeah yeah
but women only have to
like literally they're nail on head fam
women are women only nearly have to
bite yeah at your smallest yeah your
hairline is half an inch further back
than it needs to be
and you that's all she needs to say
conversation done com
that's all conversation needs to say
and it would ruin your day
i'm not bored enough for you right now
ah bye bye
bye
from there's nothing but sorry i know
you're about to continue but just
quickly there's nothing worse than a
woman saying bye to you like that
bye bye cause they always do the
duck down nod
like [ __ ] off that's basically what
they're telling you [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
see you later
bye like the the little down nod is like
so patronizing you're
confused joey's yes
you're confused oh bubba you actually
thought
someone like me would entertain someone
like you
[ __ ] off
you're really lost
goodbye
that's all you can do scream that's all
you can do
oh it's hilarious but it's so torturous
at the same time
all right this next chat said oh this
next man said rava
i'd rather have lost you than my dog
that's tough bro that is quite that's
not even funny that's just hard yeah
it's tough to swallow yeah
i got with your dad so he can have a son
he actually loves oh
no
no
that's
that's that's
that's dark
that's
dark bro
wow
i had eczema and she called me herpe
hands
[Laughter]
wow
i never loved you i loved who you
pretended to be oh
that's a that's a shank and a twist that
is a [ __ ] shanking twist
jesus christ man
huh
that's a bit too much audacity from a
man who from a man who isn't tall enough
to ride this ride
see what i mean bro
jugular and twist there's nothing i can
do about my height
there's not a thing
i'mma read one two three i'm gonna read
five back to back to back to back all
right because they're all quotations
okay and they just slap right they just
[ __ ] slap you go go go go go go go go
go go [ __ ] me
just remember my friends call you which
one
no
yeah
yeah
why should i lower my standards so you
can get a chance
yeah
but james this is the one for me what
did i tell you about speaking to me
directly
[Laughter]
you can't talk down from you can't do it
oh [ __ ] i can't get my words out you
can't talk down to me from that height
stop stop two words quotations what
muscles
no no not muscles no that's the final
straw
that's the final straw your flirting
game is as weak as your hairline
fam these man go banger off the banger
i'm sorry
have you ever heard the saying only a
face a mother could love
nah
stop you lasted all you lasted all of
two minutes and whisked and whimpered
for three to four seconds of it should i
apologize for not taking your opinion of
my skills in bed seriously
pissed wow
there was um
i remember
if you got more by the way i've got
three more all right go for it i'm gonna
do my story yeah cool three more
a guy was trying to get with me and i
said i'm not doing any charity work oh
for [ __ ]
for [ __ ] nobody could tell me that
if i'm at a dance
and i've approached a gal and she palms
me like this sorry
i'm not doing any charity work i promise
you now that club's getting closed down
i promise you now james that club is
getting closed down
because i quite refer
there's a murderer foot
something
things are gone now
blood will be leaking from somewhere i'm
not doing any charity work
women are treacherous we can't date
because i'm positive my iq is higher
than yours
yeah
positive yeah
guess let's get on university challenge
now
[Applause]
last one
your dad should have gone to sleep that
night
man said you're a waste of sperm you're
literally you're sucking up oxygen that
we as a community need
i remember you remember this
wow what a segment the girl i was dating
at uni for that short spell
um who
is funny because every bad thing she
said about me you would piss yourself
okay i don't remember that you have to
give more content continue so b
yeah
okay okay
she
would say the most cut throat things to
me
it was
terrible a frog
[Laughter]
she said saturn like
something on the lines of like
i was only dating you because you were
funny or something like that big man you
look like a frog
[Music]
i couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it women say some
hurtful [ __ ] bro women say some hurtful
[ __ ] that a man would never say to a
woman sometimes bro this is this is this
is this is the thing this is the the
narcissism of it yeah is that she told
me one time yeah
i met a guy on a night out this one we
were in a shaky space
we were in a shaky spot yeah she told me
to my face oh i met a guy in the night
out the other night
he's this tall he's this whammy yeah
yeah he's this good looking yeah yeah
i'm in love with him yeah and i remember
looking it wasn't to my face it was on
my phone i don't look at my phone
thinking has she lost her it made you
sit up it made you sit up it made me say
has she lost her [ __ ] marbles bro
yeah does she not know who she's texting
i'm not one of your girls big man if
you're gonna cheat on me do it in peace
yeah why are you disrupting my sleep
what's going on
and i was like
cool yeah cool
she was like oh yeah he asked me my
number and i gave it to him and we're
going to go and date next week
so we're done
telling me this so we're done safe say
less and then we went out on that monday
she was out yeah yeah she go and now i'm
whining the thing of course i'm wearing
this thing you were telling me that
you're linking next man i'm gonna whine
the thing fam i was one knitting she
caught me kicked up a massive stink ran
off
i asked you to fetch it
please
grab her back cousin
i can't be dealing with this drama man
and then i went to hollerer
i went back her veterans was giving me
and she said to me
i should have been listening to my
friends the whole time
you're [ __ ] ugly and they knew it
yeah
i heard justification but i defended you
her specification to me was i'm hideous
i am hideous
her friends were telling her she could
do better but she was doing the right
thing morally and defending me
while i'm out here whining next gal wow
she's basically saying you are butters
and that's an objective fact wow
but i was willing to defend you because
you're a nice guy now now you've shown
me you're not a nice guy i will agree to
the the consensus that you are hideous
wow
[Music]
fam she was [ __ ]
cutthroat wow
cutthroat
i actually saw a tweet about
something to do with when girls go back
into the group chat with the mandem some
some some let me see if i can find it
let me actually see if i can find it
hold on [ __ ] i'm annoyed i can't find it
all good that's annoyed me that's
annoyed me all good because it was very
very
what's the word i'm looking for
aligned relevant that's the word i was
looking for yeah aligned so well but
anyway
um yeah bro meanest thing a woman has
said to
you yeah
bro those quotations
why should i lower my standards so you
can have a chance fam what did i tell
you about speaking to me directly
that's brutal
what did i say about speaking to me
directly
so
when i've when i read that i thought two
visual aids came to mind it's either
what did i say to you if i speak to my
speaking to me directly i wish he's
saying you have to talk to my girl to
talk to me yeah or when we're face to
face look down when you're speaking to
me either or either raw you're losing
and that's not acceptable for me oh bro
that's not acceptable to me bro
what did i say to you what did i say to
you why are you making me repeat myself
[ __ ] what you don't i speak spanish
directly
what muscles
what must literally what muscles
i remember as well i was dating one girl
this is my girlfriend at the time when i
was dieting for a bodybuilding show and
i was probably like four weeks out okay
and i'll sit on so far sitting on the
sofa
eating white fish and broccoli okay
suffering okay so we had suffering okay
eating watching tv she i was topless she
looked at me
fam i'd lost so much i was shredded and
i had the tiniest little bit of belly
fat left yeah and she said is your
stomach supposed to look like that
i said what
she said i'm just asking
at this stage is your stomach still
supposed to look like that this
at this stage your stomach's supposed to
look like that
i said
i wanted to go
[ __ ] crazy bro
luckily i was so low calorie i didn't
have the energy
i was so low calorie
oh that's hilarious
[ __ ] they know how to pick out your
tiny little babies
they do
rip you apart because it's one of them
ones where
they've seen
the floor in you yeah they've seen the
floor but they savor it yeah oh when
they need to release it and they
practice in the mirror yeah yeah yeah
they'd be like okay this is what i'm
gonna go for this one i'm gonna say this
one
yeah and
and it's one of them ones where they
don't stutter when they speak sometimes
oh it comes with video it comes with
such vigor like you know this has been
practiced what did that go this is
pretty contained bro that girl says that
one time um i started to get out my
house that's why my mom said well
i said listen we were arguing
come on listen man come out my house man
like well i'm not having this
conversation get out my house yeah
and then um she said no i'm not leaving
i said big man yes you are she said what
you gonna do
beat me like my mum said you would
fam the fact exactly what he said
there's no stuttering there's no state
it comes out with previous you're
dangerous
confidence the day you told me that i
couldn't believe the message
i couldn't believe the message i read i
was speechless i'm not surprised
because that's why they love to render
man yeah you know when they say stuff
like this that's how they love to render
man render man's speechless and it's
just not fair
what did i tell you about speaking to me
directly speechless team what did you
say to that
my goodness
my goodness
nah
nah
it's the fact that you can't put paws on
her
that's the fact you can't put pause on
that and she knows that she knows it
she's talking you do
she's saying as much fire as she can
hoping you do yeah because then it's
worse for you of course because if that
was a brother
there's no way another man could say to
me face to face what did i tell you
about speaking to me directly no this is
you're dead yeah it's arm's house oh 100
percent farms house
ah
it's the funniest thing ever
it's the funniest thing ever we have to
wrap the episode now we literally do
guys guys
um [ __ ] i don't even think i did an
intro to this episode
we've not even done paige um patreon
yeah i know what you're gonna say yeah
um
guys head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs
um [ __ ] it out wow i can't believe i
haven't missed this in an episode for so
long patreon.com four is our shits and
gigs that's three pound a month tempe a
day you can run the p and you're gonna
get yourself an extra episode every
single thursday if you enjoyed today's
episode head on over to there now sign
up and uh join us for thursday's episode
guys if you were watching this on
youtube and you liked what you saw give
us a like make sure you chirp sitting in
the comments
um white robes and yeezys is the uniform
and we need funding for this uh cult and
the log cabin in the woods that we're
trying to bring together for you guys
um
excuse me jesus christ if you're
listening to the smooth mellow soulful
voices of j money and firelord fuegs
right now
on spotify apple google wherever you
listen to your podcast make sure please
guys give us a review uh give us a
rating it means a lot to the show we
read the reviews as well man
literally read the reviews
i go through those reviews and you guys
are keeping us i think we're at 4.9
stars
we're starting close to five like that
starting alive so guys keep on coming
please um we'd love to have a perfect
score five out of five yeah um
and guys we appreciate you as always
thank you so much for sticking with us
as always love love love gang gang see
you next time
[Music]